lulu
le caire ap apple 4e
en début de course écoutez malgré la
situation au clair de la part du groupe
il était plein de confiance
il faut quelqu'un arrive à vous faire
des confidences un phénomène portuaire
vous pourriez peut-être à faire tout
de suite pensé à faire un petit tour
que je regarde pourtant leur propre fait
madame barnier c'est pourquoi pas moi
il est normal que je trouve que ma
belle-mère pas plus tard il faut
d'abord que je te parle
il faut le faire
m
au briefing com vous parlez un peu de
votre personnage
au personnage
je suis un employé de lutte finale
l'europe le matin vers 8 heures du matin
je me réveille
pour l'heure ces catastrophes sont
qu'apparentes abord je viens demander
une augmentation
je lui fait du chantage pour l'obtenir
quand j'ai obtenu je lui demande la main
de sa chérie
je ne veux pas me la donner et je
m'étonne du chantage pour obtenir une
facilité
ensuite
je lui annonce de les voler
après
je lui annonce que je suis petite amie
de sa fille
depuis déjà un an
c'est un personnage qui fait tout ça
quelque peu les craintes que le métier
complet est frappé par amour
on peut plus sympathique nettement le
genre de personnage que vous
interprétez au cinéma pourquoi
plus que jamais 2
le règlement goodman une ampleur
considérable
dans tous les films de l'europe est une
bonne chose que les autres
l'automobile est l'autre priorité
la crise n'est pas seulement une peine
réduite à 30 degrés d'autant qu'on
peut le croire après il y en a encore
apporté quelques éléments pour
comprendre que vous êtes
on pouvait reconnaître des courtiers en
prêt
de l'autre côté de la caméra en
complète rupture
à ne pas manquer tout à fait pardonner
plus sévère oui
peut-être qu'avec moi-même première
fois
ses paroles
le comique est de dire que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile selon le pacte
dans la pub ce premier tour prédit-il
cette nouvelle structure englobant dans
le bureau grand complet se mettent en
tête
ap ce qui fait défaut par la ville
la première étape est longue
alors
paré
quant à bertrand
alors
pourquoi
lulu